I have a video coming out a little bit
later about how strange new worlds must
succeed
if we want to keep Star Trek on our
screens
and I've just watched the first episode
of season two
there will be spoilers ahead
didn't like it
I didn't think it was very good if I'm
honest the storyline was okay fair
enough
um you know there's a conspiracy on a
Klingon world that we share with the
Federation or they show the Federation
that's got loads of lithium on it
there's basically a cabal that now
control that that want the war to start
again because they made a lot of money
during the war because all the ships are
being destroyed need to be replaced and
blah blah
so they were going to trigger a new
conflict with the Klingons and the
Federation
that's fine
the Klingons look weird again
I know in this basically they're trying
to make out now that the Klingons all
look different and that's fine because
then that explains why they look
different in the movies and in the first
couple of seasons of Discovery and so on
and so on so what they've done is
they've during the episode we see lots
and lots of different type of head
gear and they all look a bit different
that's fine but it's annoying when you
start noticing that they all look
different and it's a bit you know and
then you realize why they've done it
fine there is a lot on here though it's
style over substance
very cool special effects very cool sort
of like battle brief ship battle
that there is and you know the lots of
Maneuvers and spinning round and things
but it's like this is it's unnecessary
and there's not really a lot happening
but there's a lot of lens flares and a
lot of
flipping about or whatever it feels like
JJ Abrams influence again to me kurtzman
damn you
just because you're involved in the JJ
Abrams movies doesn't mean you have to
keep bringing that into this new series
um the music all the way through the
episode I'm not saying if you haven't
seen it yet watch it with Star Wars in
mind just think does this sound a bit
like Star Wars if you close your eyes
somebody watching a Star Wars movie
any like and that's that's all I could
think about it all the way through I
didn't feel like Star Trek I felt like
Star Wars anyway
yeah get in the comments please don't
tell me whether you agree with me on
that if you you know now I've planted
the idea in your head
Anson Mount is by far the best thing
from strange new worlds and he's not in
this episode barely he's in the first
couple of minutes he has a chat with
number one he then bugs off has three
days annual leave tells spark just as
he's leaving he won't even need to be
space dog don't worry and I'm like he's
gonna lose space Dock and then weirdly
he does they steal the Enterprise now
they do divert a war so I'm sure they'll
explain this in the next episode
but
just because they divert a war doesn't
mean they just get away with this
scot-free they would still be
court-martialed
so um
the Klingons then because basically
these cabal of enemy you know people
that run this mine
a found or built
um a
Federation ship and then they're going
to attack a Klingon battle cruiser in
orbit and that's gonna start the
conflict the Enterprise then turns up
and destroys the ship right in front of
the Klingons now the Klingons don't fire
instead they have a chat with Spock
and they then decide over blood wine
that all is fine and that he's a falcon
it doesn't act like a Vulcan
my other pet peeve from this episode he
also doesn't act like Spock
we know the Spock character we know the
spot character from the original series
they are rewriting that character quite
a lot now they're basically saying that
he's emotional at the moment because he
had to release his anger during the last
episode during the attack the gaun and
he basically can't put the genie back in
the bottle just yet
we've seen that before and it's fine
but it's a little tedious and it's
actually a little cheesy to watch
talking about difficult to watch though
Carol Kane's character in this I think
his name was pelia
um now apparently she is a race that
lived nearly forever that hid amongst
humans until the 22nd century
never heard of them before but
apparently
um and she is a little bit difficult to
watch now I loved her in Scrooge and
that's the only other thing I've ever
seen her in is the only thing I know
about her
but in this her the way she speaks Etc
it's irritated
um and it's difficult and it's it's not
funny and it's just a bit strange and
it's it is difficult to watch
and thinking about funny
Star Trek's this episode kept trying to
be funny at one point um they're
stealing the Enterprise and Ortega turns
around to um Spock and just so it says
what's your thing you know you're gonna
have the commands you've got what's your
thing you know
um Picard make it so and you know blah
blah blah
um so
Pike has got his thing what's yours and
he said I would like now make the ship
go and that's it's just it they're
trying to be funny but actually they're
in the middle of stealing a federation
Starship and she then spends a good 60
seconds turn around going come on what
do you think in this irrelevant banter
which doesn't come across as funny it
just comes across as illogical mess
I really didn't like this episode I
really really wanted to and I was really
excited about it but it's really
disappointed me
I'm hoping the rest of the season picks
up when answer now does come back
I know we're going to get Kirk back in
the next couple of episodes which I'm
not looking forward to because I really
don't like the guy that they have got
playing him
sorry I just really really don't like it
but guys once you have seen it get into
the comments and tell me what you think
um and this is all opinion just because
I don't like it doesn't mean I'm a bad
person
um you know Chucky's out there that did
enjoy it please tell me why you enjoyed
it I'd love to know because I think you
know I maybe I need to look at it a
different way or something but
basically my thinking is this was style
over substance
and actually it just wasn't very good it
wasn't well written but guys I'd love to
know what you think's get in the
comments if you're new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and you
can go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where most of our new videos
do Premiere first
guys as always live long and prosper
I'll see you next time
foreign